we're back with Spencer and we've come
to see his amazing collection it's a
whole bunch of sinclair machines all
from the 1980s or or their sinclair
related at the very least go from the
set X 81 all the way up through to the
spectrum + 3 and the said 88 high
Sinclair was a British entrepreneur he
had quite a history in the electronics
business some of it more successful than
others but it was quite big in to high
fiber things and the scientific
instruments range of stuff as well but
he then went on to to make computers
said X 80 was groundbreaking in its day
when it came out and then the zx81 went
on to be the biggest selling machine of
1981 which you may I pick up the story I
don't have a said X 80 unfortunately but
if anyone's got one of they don't want
to give me away I'll happily give you a
good home because they're about four
hundred pound on eBay and it's a lovely
machine but it's not not worth that to
me the variations I mean the majority of
these are our spectrum based but yeah
but it does cover a few other things
along the way as well yeah the us
spectrum really was one of the main
computers which kicked the computer
craze in the 80s so most people are
schooled they are now a spectrum or a
Commodore 64 unless their parents were
teachers so they had a BBC model be if
that was the case but you know early 80s
they were just everywhere but one of the
biggest things about them was the price
they were cheap you know Clive Sinclair
really made things down down to a price
so yeah being that much cheaper it's
that much more affordable but underneath
that they are actually really good
machines as well really really quite
capable devices for their time that's
many minor that's playing on there
obviously that's the best game of all
time yeah there's no question about that
it is games like this that I grew up on
in the 80s and that's kind of why I'm
here today until things like these that
exciting one is that excit came out a
computer you either only had little
flashing lights and switches on the
front to operate it or you better die in
Fame type thing ridiculously expensive
kit this the computer plugged into your
telly which most
we're Teddy back then and a cassette
deck yeah so most people had to tape
tape recorder so really a cheap cheap
medium for loading and saving the games
those were Cod Sinclair's alternative to
a floppy disk because back in the day
floppy disks were quite expensive these
are little tiny tape cassette cartridges
so you've got one continuous spool of
tape which normally takes 100k of data
then it loads it a lot quicker than what
it would do from cassette tape so you've
got more storage quicker easier random
access to it as well
that's the little micro Drive cartridge
itself so you see the sport of tape in
there there's two tracks on there which
are about 50 K each old supposed to be
there in in practice they never turned
out to be quite as good as that so you
might get about eighty and ninety cave
date on there if you're lucky
I used to use them back in the 80s I've
got nail just for them yeah for
completeness effectively better yeah
that they are a practical safe way of
storing data these days no they stop
years ago there is definitely a history
of them to cut corners whenever possible
yeah so you've saved a couple of pens
here and there so there were there were
some problems one of the other big
issues is is the fact that he would
pre-announce products and take take
three orders and it'll be delivered next
month that actually turns out to be two
months three months four months down the
line some of the very early models to go
out just weren't finished they had lots
of butch wires in them and stuff like
that so yeah that that didn't help his
sudden reputation much I've they used to
use the delivery times the money wasn't
exactly in the bank accounts to start
with so if you can please say all the
stuff that gets you the money in that
you can then start to make it and
hopefully it's going to work before you
ship it out
but knee ql was announced something that
took quite a few months before that was
available but the first ones are those
they actually had the wombs hanging out
at the back on a little plug in extra
circuit board because they weren't
finished so they had to ship something
and they said well that kind of normally
sometimes work so ship them out because
we've got customers that need them the
original spectrum as it was a huge big
hit
obviously there was pressure on it on
him to come up with something bigger
better and he wanted to get into the
into the business world a bit more so
the the QL was launched in 1984 so and
that come out with a proper keyboard
almost real caves yes it's just like a
keyboard that was obviously an
improvement on the dead fish keyboard of
the spectrum if you felt that flesh
likely buried just like that the
spectrum was the event at the end of 84
we had the spectrum plus which is
effectively exactly the same computer as
the original spectrum it the same
motherboard only difference being you've
got the veal keyboard and a reset button
other than that spectrum plus and a
spectrum 48k of the same beast
that's why yes
yes because the apparel socket was
always a little bit fragile and if
you've done it too quickly he could he
could damage it so yeah having a reset
button probably saved a lot of machines
there yes yes and there's there's
there's no shutdown procedure or
anything like that there's no startup
procedure either it's just a case of
yeah there's power it works there's no
power doesn't work that's that's a
simple is he caught
was a lot more flexible there's also a
decent sound chip in there as well
as opposed to the beep beep beep that
you got out of the old spectrum a whole
number of sectors or technically we use
clusters which is multiple sectors join
together
[Music]